here we go oh yeah this is great oh gosh
I just changed some settings hey guys
how's it going I'm extremely excited
because I've got a wonderful box right
here in front of me and was in this box
is something extremely exciting this is
the new DJI phantom 4 drone and I'm in
my parents house which means I've got
free rein to fly pretty much wherever I
want
unlike in the city I'm feeling there's a
box inside of a box so we've got up
first open the first box god I'm sorry
the best part about the new DJI phantom
4 is there's obstacle avoidance as
expected there is another box this is
great this is just great this is nice
this comes in as little protective case
yeah unlock oh it opens this way do mi
mi ma can I get in here let me in here
I'm getting too excited I cannot handle
the excitement yes crank alright great
great open all I'll open all the wet
maybe we uh
get over it oh um Wow so for those of
you guys you may see this little thing
right here and think hey this is
unlocked it's not you need to do a
slight turn and then let's watch how
simple this is anyway we're going right
along God smells good
I'm like shaking I'm so nervous the best
part about these is before you needed to
screw in the propellers and now you just
snap them on and off which is incredible
and it'll make it so much easier
Scrat one with this little guy right
over items that tray is this for extra
batteries which is great because I just
ordered two batteries if you have a
previous version of phantom all new
batteries which is great because they
are redesigned and this was to be
lighter and it will last longer but if
you have old batteries they won't work
which is downfall so if anybody wants to
buy some old phantom batteries let me
know I've got some for sale where do I
even start
I better check to make sure this audio
source I do like during the camera I
tripped over the Box fell into it this
is just wild alright let's get this set
up
so these have a black tip and a silver
tip so you have to make sure that you
line them up with each of the warning
colors here because I just try to attach
one and you do not fit and that was the
problem clearly I didn't raise the dress
check the battery level all right
everything's charging up and now I'm
gonna just wait until the batteries are
charged and then we're gonna take this
thing outside to calibrate and then fly
I'm so pumped
Oh guys it's 6:10 sunset is it 6:17 we
gotta get this shot I'm really tired
I don't wake up for anything I never
wake up I have to wait oh I had to wake
up today hi baby drone which way the Sun
comes up
hey looks good I stay here 6:15 boot it
up somewhere update available now
first time I've flown the Phantom four
aircraft is warming up about 6:17 right
now
go lit up okay
beginner mode not for me
Oh
I'm an idiot
our little Niva recording of the drone
yeah cool since that's a great idea
except there's no freaking Sun right now
let's just take off take this out of
dinner mode
I am freezing we're at 53% battery the
drone is all the way up there I wanted
to do a little bit more but I wasted my
battery on trying to figure out how to
fly
very successful drone flying warning oh
that was fun
god I'm freezing see you guys in the
next tech Tuesday bye I'm using my
camera as a mirror